everyone my name is Matt I talk really
quickly I apologize I'm going to try to
stay slow but within like 30 seconds
from now I'm going to forget all about
that uh so yeah I worked on Das for a
very long time so of these four I've got
a favorite um and actually had totally
different talk planned um as of like two
weeks ago and two weeks ago we play some
benchmarks it was really fun it's a fun
collaboration so I thre my old talk
turns out you just you can go on to like
the P out website and just change your
talk description entirely and no one
stops you um it shows up instantly on
the website it's great um so we're going
to talk about benchmarks um benchmarks
for these projects at Large Scale sort
of SQL databas processing uh tagline is
the battle that no one wins we're going
to try different scales different
environments and everyone's going to
fail different ways including desk Das
is not wi
this um we see lot of charts today um
those charts are going to look if you
don't like listening to talks you like
looking at results instead those of the
tpch coil. I put this up like yesterday
was not local optimized I apologize
we're looking look at things like this
local 10 gab Cloud 10,000 10 terab we're
going to see what do does for different
scales so be
fun uh but before that we're going to do
super boring so here some background on
ppch and data framing stuff that maybe
you know maybe you don't know um little
charts which is super exciting uh and
they'll talk about like what's the I
want and that's what's like fun I think
for the like engineering
performance um then I'll like sell you
some
stuff um so we got tpch if you want got
some results there okay background kind
ofor
um first there's pandas let us like all
give a round of applause for pandas is
like aside from Exel it's probably the
package that like has had the most
impact on the earth uh or among like
that analysis people but uh pandas do
not operate at like the 10 tery scale in
cloud and there are other options that
people use today U or people are curious
about using today historically people
used spark and Spark is definitely the
standard in the space there's dask dask
is like lots of things that aren't out
of AC but you s of ADD dask and pandas
because that dat frame thing which does
sort of more dat frame of stuff there's
duck DB and polers which are both really
well so spark and DK both are
distributed computing systems they're
both a little bit older they're both a
little bit slower du and polar as they
come on they like lightning fast on a
single machine and it's interesting to
see sort of where where they fall down
where they they
succeed different things um historically
look my dask hat here dask has sucked at
bench marks it is like very easy to use
dask poorly and it's a very popular
project so you like want to show that
your project is better than the incent
include dask and your benchmark recently
though a bunch of things uh happened
with dask uh pandas got a lot faster
with pandas 2 lot ofd types like
massively changed memory performance
things like copy and WR we redeveloped
our shuffling algorithm or like sort
join kinds of things and we're now
adding PR optimization these four
features actually like creates a new D
data frame which is actually kind of
fast down which is fun uh Patrick who's
here I gave a talk on this earlier this
morning so dask and pandas are fast now
here's a quick video so if you've used
dask dashboards You' seen charts like
this and I'm actually showing on the
left is like new dask and on on the
right is
old and some things to know there's some
progress Parts down here showing you the
progress they're both progressing in the
beginning just
fine we're also going to know up here
there's memory loose here on the new on
the old system it's you know it's fine
but it's you know like 30% on the new
system very nicely bounded memory very
stable very clean on the right we see a
lot of really exciting activity super
fun uh but also like it's red it's kind
of scary it's going to SL down a little
bit this memory is creepy up I'm getting
kind of
nervous um on the left really boring uh
actually so if you go to a booth we got
this running all the time to try to
attract you to the booth because it's
exciting um and the the new system sucks
because it is so boring it is like not
nearly as flashy as the old system which
has lots of like flashy lights uh but
yeah so the old system now is kind of
scary it's orange it's yelling at you
it's spilling the disc in a bad way
system the left just chug it along so
this is the difference this s of thing
think about dask if you're familiar with
dask historically you use it a large
scale you've seen slow things like
what's on the right and today you'll see
boring and fast things
like so um again as are fast now
boringly so that is that is so but uh
let's talk a little bit about not ask
but the benchmarks we going to play with
so there is an organization of TPC which
manages a variety of standard benchmarks
the sort of tabular SE database space
tpch is a database Benchmark it is very
standard many people implement it they
comp against each other uh and it is
very sort of join sorting Group by
agregation heavy honestly the stuff like
pandas and Das don't get used for that
often this more for like a serious SQL
database but other people did it so we
SED copying it um fine with it the
queries look like this you can't see
this is is way too small but they're
complex lots of lots of bridges lots of
joints lots of sort complex
behat that's the queries that we're
going to run we're going to run those
queries on a variety of scales ranging
from 10 gab to 10 terabytes THX range
there and we're going to run it on my
MacBook Pro or on a bunch of machines in
the cloud those are the different
environments we're going to play with
and we're going to see how that operates
my MacBook Pro is about 2 years old it's
an M1 chip uh it's like running Chrome
in the background I haven't like cleaned
everything off it's living a busy data
science workspace
environment uh on Amazon we were running
on m6i which is standard chipsets until
yesterday when some company stole all of
them and we had to switch with different
chipset which you can do on coil really
easily uh but it's like like a very
boring Choice okay uh we're going to
keep a number of cores and this the cost
constant across all systems we're going
to use duct D and polers on a single
machine because that's what they can do
and that's work there many small
machines that's kind of want to see the
benefits and
drawbacks that's like this is the
landscape of the
computer again these are our projects uh
I really don't like benchmarks because
people cheat unintentionally right they
cheat unintentionally a few ways you
keep tuning until you win and then you
publish you like don't publish ahead of
time there's a strong publication bias
uh you also focus on where you win so
like in this top I'm going to focus I'm
top way more about cloud and way more
about scale because what I think is
really important if Richie were here is
Richie here no uh if Richie were here he
would focus way more on single machines
in memory 10 gabes we actually been
collaborated a bun uh so there's like we
work fun and then finally I'm just like
way better at TK than you are uh and
like I'm way
worse I'm way worse at spark and duct
and poers than like those relative
authors are and so I can just like
navigate the Das way better uh we're
going to see actually I I I think I'm
doing spark wrong spark does not perform
well in these benchmarks as well as I
would expect I expect it's because I'm
done not because spark is bad um so uh
Patrick just just whispered I disagree
um so we're trying to address this bias
in a few ways uh we didn't choose the
benar site we chose whatever poers did
we didn't write the queries we chose
what pollers did um the data generation
we didn't do we
sldv um and we're aving configuration
options I can actually configure D to
run about twice as fast I'm going to
show you if I like super saturate some
Cordes in some situations and you
configure others so we're like trying to
be honest well that's impossible we're
not going to be honest it's like the
bias is a so to address that bias though
we're working with poar people so like
this is Richie and I we spent a lot of
time the last couple of days we actually
got polar S3 access to be like two to
three times faster in the last few days
was super fun um we've like I think
released polers like two or three times
also in the last few days trying to get
these things better um um poers would
like you to know sorry Richie would like
you to know uh Richie is the polar guy
which like you know that this is using
the polar streaming engine out of for
system which is way newer and isn't as
optimized I he also like you know that
like or I want you know that poers is is
younger than everyone else and it's
moving really fast so poers will also
not perform very well At Large Scale but
that's mostly just because of like
timing for spark we're talking to a
company called syn Computing super cool
company they uh look through your spark
logs do a bunch of magic and like tell
you what configurations you want for
spark jobs um fun group they do a lot of
spark most this guy Vu on the right
super cool guy he used for a paler
optimizing all the customer spark
workloads um our attempts at prig spark
very bad they're now better like I
assume there's still L see things about
that um so so charts I was Bing stuff
thank you for being boring with me let's
look at some
charts so I'm going to start with local
on 10
gab uh dask is on the left that's blue
spark is on the right and that's light
blue those are the distributed systems
and they're going to correlate the
distributed systems and the single
machine systems will behave somewhat
similarly to each other duct TV is
orange and polar is is red they're in
the middle um they're doing way better D
spark get their butts handed to them at
this scale um I will say I was actually
kind of happy that Das was not way worse
than spark we expected to be worse than
spark but we weren't historically would
way worse in performance people have
used D it's like the easy familiar
choice not because it's the fast choice
and it's actually sometimes the past
choice now just F uh as we scale up to
100 gabes things get weird
I want to emphasize this is on my
MacBook Pro and it's like running Chrome
and other crap in the background some of
these systems are not designed to run
with a bunch of other crap in the
background um so like in some cases like
pis actually just fails um this is I
think because PG is expecting my entire
machine and it like swap has weird
swapping errors that I get a bunch um
but duck DB PO is doing pretty well kind
of has a hard time that's 37 G7 has a
lot of reir large joins
um you du also
doesn't I'm going to shift now go back
toy to 10 gabes we're going to shift to
Cloud so this is showing you the
difference when you switch to Cloud
everything is normaliz and we're going
to see this in a bit this is S3 access
so we reading that from S3 we're doing
the query off that and S3 is such a
bottleneck that all like the super fast
high performance magic new systems have
doesn't actually play into into actually
to see that managing S3 is actually how
you win these benchmarks at a large
scale um still scale those S of s sys do
pretty well Pol couldn't do query 2 this
is depending on which version we we run
out of qu 2 or quy 3 doesn't work for
poers um swi to 100 gab and now dask and
Spark start coming into more of a
dominant plan as we increase scale and
more scalable systems can do better
which is not so
um D is fash Park this is not what we
expected uh most of the time actually
these F all for happy like mostly we
competing at spark we're very happy to
see this if you use spark today and want
to care about speed and like ease of use
and friendliness you should
use um going up to 1,000
gigabytes
um High spark and polar have some
problems uh dask and dub kind of do okay
really honestly the winner overall the
these things is kind of duct DV duck DV
seems to do pretty well a variety of
scales um when actually switch up to 10
terabytes I actually couldn't get smart
to run in less than an hour for my like
tests with stop running um and duck TV
can handle like four of the
queries um da is also like odly the only
system that runs across all scales
completes all the time uh like the
boring part of the the video that I
showed you earlier is actually really
nice it just like just run all the
time so uh those are some results I'm
going to now get into sort of more
analysis mode we're going to talk
through what we're seeing what's good
what's so um yeah so first no tool wins
consistently you should make different
choices based on your environment based
on your experience level based on I feel
like SQL I don't like SQL one machine or
many machines for the cloud or not the
cloud no single machine no single system
is is quite all the time
um and also no one is anywhere near
optimal on cloud like dask does pretty
well on cloud and we found like a 2 to
5x speed improvements that I think were
available to us like I can show you how
dask is dog slow right now and the fact
that we are neck and neck with everybody
means that everyone else is also dogs SL
it's very like it's I am surprised at
how bad we all are on cloud access um so
let talk about us three um
I'm going to so these are all running on
coiled I can go look at my dashboard I
can look at
workloads there like some feed back I
apologize um I cannot fix that though um
this is showing
you the the seven queries that were one
with with that um quer one quer two quer
three Etc and we can see those are the
kinds of activities we're doing uh
across
time if we look at the Baseline metrics
during those times you see use you see
memory use we also see network access
Focus also on network access for a
second on quy one which is mostly just
outling thatou group Iration we get
about 50 megabytes per second 60
megabytes per second per note a bunch of
noes so it adds up to bigger than that
but I honestly expect more like 500
megabytes per second per node on these
kinds of machines so we are not
operating anywhere near performance
limits uh oddly if you track this down
it's actually Arrow uh arrow is
surprisingly fast on my MacBook
surprisingly slow on a Linux machine in
the CL um we did like a bunch of
collaboration with the a folks over last
week they're like aware of the problem
they're on our offsite right now but
hopefully over the next few weeks we can
a this a lot faster um things are
strange um what's also interesting
though is that like it's not just us
that it's slow so also weird things I
was just running uh experiments just
like just downloading bytes no dask no
pandas no paret just downloading bytes
and I can get like on a tiny machine I
can get and doing D things 100 megabytes
per second then it switches to 200 megab
per second a few minutes in like Amazon
does strange things with Adit shaping um
it's a little bizarre if we look at
projects like Duck DB duck is on a
massive instance uh it C utilization is
super low it doesn't need the size of
inance but it does do a great job of
grabing you know a gigabyte per second
and it climbs up here to like you know
two gigabytes per second on that machine
Dr is handled three really really well
but D even though it's kind of crappy
one
machine um we aggate over many machines
we actually get you know actually you're
peing at about like 7 GES per
second so dask sucks at S3 P but because
of the distributes we can still out
compete a highly optimized system
because S3 B doesn't scale Lally like
sizeing inst type um so this is where I
think as we scale up this is why the
distributed systems are doing better
they can spread as three band across
more machines for mostly
As also of interest uh spark here's the
spark one spark is also super slow on
network um this is
machine like 40 megabytes per second it
Peaks up here at like 50 Maybe you know
7 um spark is also very very slow on
that's reband the difference with spark
is that it's also peing on CP
utilization sparkers actually not
bottleneck on their S3 bandwidth they're
getting very bad S3 bandwidth they're
getting very bad at S3 bandd because
they actually are just so inefficient at
reading thata they're like in memory
computation is bad um so again there's
like if you had the performance of duck
DV and the scalability of spark that
would be very powerful there's a lot of
room for improvement there if only there
was a system that could be fast and
scalable at the same time um what
do um okay also briefly talk about inter
machine communication so this is a this
is a profile so let's look at again
looking at dask this is a dask p stream
this is showing you scale 100 I think so
gigabytes what all the Das workers are
doing they're mostly reading Park the
blue bits are reading Park the green
bits are uh transferring data in between
different workers this is the cost of
being distributed because I spent a lot
of time communicating across machines uh
if we look at actually the the profile
so people may not be with flame graph
profiles I apologize I exclude you for a
second this chunk this big thing is all
reading prop this is just us spending
time in Arrow trying to grab bites and
de serialize them this bit over here is
inter machine communication this is the
the fact that we are um you know on
manyi machines we got to communicate
it's like way slower than this park
speed is way more important than this
stuff this thing right here is
pandas and so like if you say oh like
pandas is slow we need to make pandas
faster it really doesn't matter like
pandas could be twice as slow no one
would notice because it isn't
our or maybe better say p is actually
fast enough for around all these things
really well p is
not
okay moving
on exactly spark like spark like spark
is really good at getting high SE
utilization despite not actually going
fast like if what you want to do is like
keep receipt use pay like spark is the
best tool sorry I'm like trying to be
really nice to everybody but like it's
been oddly frustrating working with
spark
um yeah so anyway Network bandwith
should be like hundreds of megabytes per
second uh memory band network is gabes
megabytes band is like tens of
gigabytes um V the the spark guy
actually he like uh he was really
excited about our our dashboard you see
all this stuff wow that's never had that
in spark that's possible um and I was
asking him like great how do I optimize
Network like what are the what are the
configuration options make that better
answer was like oh no one like network
is never the Bott it's always CPU memory
we're always optimiz CP memories that's
the slow part spark which is crazy to me
because again like these
numbers like memory and CPU should be
operating orders of magnitude fast than
Network and the fact that they're not is
very
confusing there's a lot of room for
opportunity Beyond
what's okay other takeaway duct DB
performers adorably from small scale to
large scale they ran every query pretty
well up until sort of the 10 terab rate
hly proba design for it like did really
well scale um so K is to be it was like
a winner an agate across this pmark it's
them for now uh that's is okay uh we're
B BYO by shuffling actually a lot of
room for a grouping of both of those
we've been doing this for like two weeks
now I'm actually really excited about
taking those numbers way down there's
actually a lot of a lot of space for us
there and we're not that a by pandas
pandas is actually doing their job
pretty
well so uh last topic is deployment
uh where I like try to sell you stuff so
I work I work at a company called coils
which is like a d company we mostly sell
D stuff um and we make it really easy to
run
v um and we built a system that makes it
easy to SP turn on machines and easy to
get software on those machines run DK on
those machines that's like really
accessible to people without
understanding a lot of like deep
technology um and what we found so like
if you ask for actually I'm to just do
this live um if you ask
for you maybe we'll ask for you know 100
workers with 64 megabytes each we do
this in
framfor um and we use Arm because I like
arm um I'm just doing this from python
from my laptop and what this is doing is
it is scraping my laptop trying to look
packages I have it's making a
specification that they're going to ship
up to the cloud is then going to
provision 100 machines machines are
going to come on in about a minute
they're going to download all those
packages connected to that securely so I
can from python create whatever
infrastructure I want and I can then
like run compute stuff on that pretty
well super powerful task users love it
um it's like the easiest way to get
machines um what we found oddly is that
people were uh using coil clusters but
like the median cluster size wasn't 100
or 10 it was one and they didn't like a
big D dat frame computation they just R
like a single python function and I shut
down the cluster like what what is going
on why are you using a framework to just
run a single python function in the
cloud and it turns out they just like
wanted an AWS Lambda that was
sensible um and so what we say
internally is like our core competency
is actually just like turning servers on
and off uh and like making sure they
have the right software installed um and
so so uh that actually is like a
interesting growth area for us um so we
think of this a heavyweight Serv option
this actually how I ran L benchmarks
with wrote Patrick wrote a blog post
about DV on foil and like a bunch of
random people start to show how running
effil when paying this money it was um
so return that to an API you just like
Decor your function with the hard where
you want first time it runs create the
VM all subsequent times it just runs
pretty and you can like you know run it
in parallel if you want so it's cool
relative to Amazon Lambda is like a
minute long spin up time so you should
only use this with big things but if
you're cool with that mle if you're cool
with that minute long spin up time it's
great you get whatever hard R you want
you want a100 if you can find one go for
it it's like 10x cheaper than Amazon
Lambda Amazon Lambda like markup is huge
um and it's just like good for just
general b data processing so it's neat
it's been fun um there's lots of
examples I just showed you
want a GPU in MacBook Pro function with
a GM GPU
type um this is how we ran tests with po
this is all just a p test test speed um
and I'm just like annotating P test
function with quot functions and it just
like runs on the cloud instead which is
neat it's like been a nice sort of
composable tool with prefa like their
prefa task and just like starts running
on a big ma it's been fun um
so I can run Das because I've got coiled
and I can run duct and polar these like
single machine systems also coiled due
to this function thing how to run
spark options were like figure out
Amazon EMR or use data bricks uh those
are both like non unpleasant options and
I that it was actually easier for us to
just reinvent EMR on PO EMR is a service
to SM onon either first to like reinvent
this on Quil so this was originally
plannned to be an April Fool's joke
uh but actually was like not that hard
to build so now it's like a build Spar
on quote um it's neat I can like the
cluster smart cluster events like drive
my
laptop you shouldn't use this it's like
kind of just for this project but you
could it's I think a better experience
than
canm so very briefly that's out of frame
pitch and is still cool um so I'm like
putting on my like dask bias hat here
for example dask is the only project
that ran off both the queries and it ran
them in sensible time no other project
is able to do that that's my like
current claim to thing um it was the
fastest of large scale but probably
we're being done probably SAR can do
these things I'm just not finding a
configuration option there's a lot of
future work for us to do to actually
figure out what's going on here again
all of this is very new um and fresh
these are all very blary results please
don't like I was about to say please
don't take this to your boss and say the
dask is the best but actually that
okay um but know that it will get even
better over time
um yeah and I think mostly like I'm
excited about this possibility of
getting the scalability of spark but
without the like 10x slowdown that spark
seems to experience on a single machine
if we got to like half the speed of Po
in memory that would be a fantastic
result and I think an aable one Rec
coiled you should us use us SP money
we're great um the cloud can actually be
really easy and really cheap it was like
easy to build this Benchmark system
where I'm spitting up all these machines
right all these different scales all
these different pypes I have all run a
high test fixture um you two can do that
Co makes it really fun that's it that's
my
um we have you Applause
[Applause]
now so we've got I think 10 minutes
question
question raise your hand gentl mic and
raise your hand to the next person so we
can
like um so my question is regarding um
the benchmarks so you mentioned that S3
was acting as a
modene I want to know like what what was
your networking set up for running
benchmarks do you set up some point or
something do you go over there because
your bottom could be there
internet yeah so these These are these
are easy2 these are e to instances on
the region that is where the data is
stored so I'm like doing a direct like
this is this is how everybody operates
um it's it depends like if you set up
the the private link or this is not
using private link right you're not
using that correct because your um your
bottom link would be there because
has to go through end oret in order to
get to3 I agree if using private link
that would be a bottom L but we're not
this is like coil generally does very
raw Cloud infrastructure you turn on two
instances for you as fast as one can
turn them on you off the as fast as one
can do so it we give you just like a raw
ec23
option good question there's I mean
you're pointing out there's a lot of
possible complexity in doing this in
general like the coil CL infastructure
Engineers are pretty pretty good at
doing this they've like set up pretty
sful things you can like really shoot
yourself in the foot in the cloud um if
you don't set up networking correctly it
can be slow it must be really expensive
and also networking depends a lot on the
instance choose I actually myself found
um like making some right sizing
decisions ons and suddenly my traffic
dropped and I was like I'm getting so
fire I what because of that because it
depends a lot on this yeah I'm trying to
BR up a notebook for test all the
different instance types to find the
best like bandwidth per dollar thing
yeah which is super easy to do with Quil
go for it so you mentioned that you
mentioned that of course the plan is to
make uh that's faster and scale even
better than what it does right now um
can you maybe share a little bit about
the road Maple and what's um exciting in
the next maybe six 12 months and the
development of that sure uh if you're on
YouTube go look at Patrick's talk which
talked about all these things we were
supposed to do this actually in reverse
order uh so you would go into his talk
and find all the answers to that
question great question
um uh the biggest most exciting thing
right happening right now is we're
adding a lot of C optimization to that
frame so we can like push column
projections down we can reorder joints
and do make things a lot more um
robustly efficient historically the dask
developers can do amazing performance
with dask but like nonexperts easily
shoot themselves in the foot they have a
bad sort of median experience and we're
doing a lot of things things a lot more
robust that's sort of medium developer
experience um so that's high level C
optimization that's things like faster
shuffling alms um generally avoiding any
kind of memory um overflow which is why
we're super stable is why we can with
everything so those things in general
speaking T frame is a lot more foolproof
um that's like
maybe um uh I'm asking something I you
don't know right now but um is there any
plan are there any plans on adding
another another kind of data type so
like arrays uh data frames maybe I don't
know something similar to topv or uh
something like can I guess I'm asking
for a lot here but
like uh like a an extra data type an
extra class yeah so the question is can
can d add new data types like strs like
arrays like lists inside of D and the
answer is so first D is many things like
Das is workflow management and
multi-dimensional Rise stuff at very
large scale D data frame is Das plus
pandas together and so really the
question is can pandas add those things
the answer is yes pandas can add those
things with arrow extension data types
so Arrow has all the data types we just
mentioned and pandas and Arrow coming a
lot closer together and so pandas is
getting a lot of that same um
capabilities because a was pushing
forwards in general like the Das Space
is really messy because there's like
five different libraries are all
collaborating to make things happen so
yes ring all those things but actually
like Patrick is add those things and the
arrow adding those things um and we all
benefit from the in the sort of shared
community
structure you a question yeah I don't
know if this is a very question but how
does this compare with our data W like
snowflake where uh they also now
have yeah great question so the question
is how does this with snowflake or just
generate dat
warehouses also good to point out that
uh data bricks also has Photon I didn't
wasn't testing photons just open source
spark Photon tend get that of 2x speed
Improvement which I think we can still
be uh yeah so I don't know I haven't
tested against noake and that would be
great work to do in general I think the
data
warehouses can often get a lot more uh
like ASM totic but often talk better
performance because they know a lot more
about their data uh the tools that we
discussed here operate on data that they
don't know sort of this question in data
tooling are they separate or they sort
of all inone um I would expect snowflake
to win as K has got more and more
complex but I also expect snake to
become less convenient as organizations
get more and more complex people want to
sort of read a data do actually boost on
it it's like do a
SN yeah just lots of different
tools um so you did not use theery the
desk
Optimizer I 100% you did yes yes much
slower without and then another question
I had is you said you use C instance for
holders andv is that with it so my
company just buys everything in house we
have like these crazy vertically scaled
machines that we run uh you know data
frame computations on would that be a
fair Benchmark comparison or you think
that's a different type of test yeah so
the question is like look I we at a
company we just buy massive machines do
these benchmarks reflect into that
environment is that roughly yeah no they
don't you should run benchmarks in that
environment that are different right
this is like my own personal bias we
mostly help companies who are doing
large scale data processing on cloud
infrastructure and so this is mostly a
talk about do without processing
structure uh different Hardware
different software Patricks like
interact in different ways so I would
not take these lessons to be broadly
applicable you should do benchmarking
different
parts is there an issue I call on GitHub
for the arrow S3 improvements that you
mentioned or have they not raised tiet
yeah so this is all um here uh
paration C if you go to arrow and look
for author M Rockman you will
find oh no this like the last couple of
weeks were just like me talking to
Panda's Arrow polar spark it was a super
fun time it's like a really fun
collaboration also all these people are
European making for like 500 a.m. every
day um no offense to
Europeans it's annoying sometimes uh we
should all have an Iceland together um
yeah there's like a ton of Open Source
stuff on this and if you go to one of
these it'll link to other issues and
there's lots of notebooks that are you
know interesting
so other
questions okay thank you all for your
time um in
general benchmarks are fun I always
hated benchmarks cuz like someone gets
up and tells other tool was best I hope
I kind of achieved in not doing that
today um I'm also really excited about
the collabration here uh Richie and I
actually would like love to work
together on like vask poers at scale
beating spark they both have that goal
and mostly we're just waiting until we
can kill all of the other
bottlenecks uh and my my guess is that's
actually not going to happen like guess
that right but all of the Bott neck will
be like 5x faster than spark and never
will be Happ
um but it' be fun it's fun see a lot
collaboration in this space
non-competitive and c and I'm excited
about that thank you
[Applause]
all